بعدها عمل تقريبا على رفعها يافطه معارضه
للحرب في اوكرانيا خلال نشره للتلفزيون
الروسي الحكوميه الصحفيه مارينا
خرجت عن صمتها وكشفت تفاصيل عمليه تهريبها
من روسيا حيث كانت قيد الاقامه الجبريه
الصحفيه المتحذره من اصول روسيه واوكرانيه
تكشف ايضا في كتاب يزور اليوم في المانيا
عن علاقاتها مع شخصيه مقربه من السلطه في
روسيا وبعد التفاصيل عن خطط الدعايه
المعتمده في القنوات التلفزيه التابعه
معنا في الاستوديو ازمير عمار الحميداوي
عمار اهلا بك تابعت المؤتمر الصحفي اذا
الذي عقدته اليوم هذه الصحفيه الروسيه
ملافت حول ما كشفته في عمليه
التهريبها من روسيا اولا شجاعه هذه
الصحفيه التي وقفت امام نظام تعسفي
وديكتاتوري على حد وصفها هذه الشجاعه التي
تبينت ايضا في عمليه خروجها من موسكو
باتجاه بلد لم تحدد لدواعي امنيه يعني هذا
البلد والحدود التي عبرتها قالت بعد عمليه
يعني مشاركتها في هذه النشره نشره الاخبار
التي هي تعتقد بان رئيس فلاديمير وبوتين
لطالما كان معتاد ان يشاهد النشرات
الاخبار على حد وصفها لانها يحب ان يشاهد
مذيعات الاخبار الجميلات هكذا وصفت هذه
الخطوه اختيارها هذه اللحظه قالت لانه
يمكن هو
يتابع وانا كنت اريد ان اتحدى هذه الحرب
بين خلال هذه الحركه وصفت ايضا الظروف
التي تحيط باقرار الروسي الدخول في هذه
الحرب في يعني في هذه في هذا المقتطف من
مداخلتها نتعرف على ظروف الاعلاميين
وكيفيه تغطيه هذه الاحداث في روسيا
فلنستمع اليها
ان الاحتجاج في روسيا اليوم مستحيل بمجرد
ان نحاول ذلك تدمر حياتنا تماما انها دوله
شموليه حقيقيه تبدو مثل عهد السالين كعقاب
يستخدم الكرملين القمع السياسي والنفسي
اذا بعد كل هذه يعني الظروف القاسيه هذا
التعتيم يعني تكبدت عنها الهروب وهي حامله
لسوار مراقبه وضع لانها كانت تحت الاقامه
الجبريه قالت بانها تخلصت او استطاعت
التخلص من هذا سوار قبل مغادره منزلها
واتجهت وغيرت سبع مرات السيارات التي كانت
تقول لها الى الحدود وانها اجبرت على
السير لمسافه طويله في منتصف الليل للوصول
نقطه الالتقاء التي كانت هناك مجموعه على
تواصل معها من خلال مراسلونا بلا حدود
بانتظارها وتامين وصولها الى يعني النقطه
الاخيره وهي فرنسا اذا تحدثت وكاننا كنا
نستمع الى روايه من روايات الافلام يعني
افلام التشويق وكذلك المخابرات وبالسؤال
عن فيما اذا كان هناك داخل الفرنسيه في
عمليه اخراجها من موسكو
رفضت التعليق عن هذا الامر بينما استدرج
رئيس منظمه مراسلون بلا حدود قائلا باننا
اعتمدنا على اصدقاء
صحفيين في الوسط الاعلامي اصدقاء
للصحفيه الروسيه واصدقاء لنا وتمكنا من
اخراج هذه الصحفيه وانقاذها التي كانت
تواجه عقوبه السجن لعشر سنوات
لاعتراضها على هذه الحرب خاصه وان
الاعتراض بات يعتبر جنحه يعاسب عليها
القانون الروسي وقالت بان العديد من
الزملاء الروس الصحفيين تعرضوا الى
مضايقات والسجن بسبب الاعتراض على هذه
الحرب
شكرا جزيلا لك زميل عمار الحميداوي شكرا
لك